dans les années 1960
le mathématicien grégory channing conçu
un nombre mystérieux qui renfermait tous
les secrets des mathématiques toutes les
démonstrations de tous les plus grands
théorème de mathématiques de la
conjecture de gaulle barre à l'hypothèse
de riemann doute était grave et dont le
nombre conçu par tahiti il n'y avait
qu'à lire les décimales de ce nombre
pour connaître tous les secrets des
mathématiques
toutefois avant de publier son joyau qui
a été pris le temps de vérifier que les
secrets de son ombre ne serait jamais
révélé chytil s'assurera ainsi qu'aucun
mathématicien ne pourrait jamais
découvrir les mystères de sombres et que
c'est mystère demeurait donc à jamais
incalculables
vous y croyez à cette théorie du complot
et bien tout ce que je viens de dire en
fait eu lieu
le joyau de shay thing est aujourd'hui
appelée la constante oméga de chat in et
7 aux médias enferme bel et bien tous
les mystères des mathématiques et même
tous les mystères de toutes les
mathématiques étudié par les
mathématiciens des axiomes de p and o à
la théoriser d'accès en passant par la
théorie des types avec unis valence tous
les mystères de toutes les mathématiques
sont quelque part dans l'eau mais qu'un
cheating le seul hic c'est qu'on sait
également qu on ne saura jamais quelque
chose de l'oméga de tschaï tine
enfin on sait que c'est un nombre entre
0 et 1 et on connaît ces quelques
premières décimales
mais c'est tout pire que ça cetin a
démontré qu on en saura jamais beaucoup
plus tout ça parce que les décimales de
l'oméga sont impossible à calculer
elles sont tout à fait bien défini mais
elles sont incalculables et même des
arguments non calculatoire qui
s'appuierait par exemple sur des
mathématiques non constructive comme azf
s'est seront incapables de déterminer
plus qu'une poignée de décimales de
l'oméga l'oméga est bien défini mais il
est aussi très inaccessibles pour les
mathématiques usuelles
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de vous
expliquer ce qu'est l'oméga
pourquoi il est aussi puissant et
pourquoi il est aussi inatteignable et
on va commencer bien sûr par ce qu'est
l'oméga de cetin de façon grossière il
s'agit tout simplement de la probabilité
qu'un programme écrit au hasard soit un
code qui termine oui parce que quand on
exécute un programme il y a deux
possibilités soit le programme va
tourner pendant un moment renvoyer un
résultat et s'arrêter comme par exemple
un programme qui calculerait la
multiplication autres de nombre soit le
programme peut s'exécuter mais ne jamais
s'arrêter
ce sera typiquement le cas d'une boucle
infinie dans le code comme par exemple
dans celui que j'ai écrit à l'écran ou à
chaque étape on remplace x par x x 1 - x
temps que x est positif
en partant de x est égal à 1,2 me alors
là bien sûr j'ai donné des exemples très
simple où nous autres humains sommes
capables de prédire le comportement du
programme
mais parfois deviner si un programme
termine est un problème beaucoup plus
difficile ce sera le cas notamment aussi
au lieu d'utiliser un langage de
programmation comme python on écrit
désormais le programme en code machine
en particulier le langage plus
fondamental qu'ils soient si on en croit
turing c'est celui d'une machine de
turing universel comme on l'a vu dans un
épisode de la série sur lie à une
machine de turing est universelle est
une tête de lecture relativement simple
muni d'un ruban sur le call le code peut
être écrit nos machines modernes de nos
téléphones à nos ordinateurs sont de
telles machines elles ont un
microprocesseur l'équivalent de la tête
de lecture qui va analyser l'équivalent
du ruban à savoir thé fumant la mémoire
vive de l'ordinateur en pratique toute
l'information du ruban ou à l'intérieur
de la tête de lecture est binaire
c'est-à-dire qu'elle correspond à
l'équivalent d'une suite de 0 et de 1
on peut ainsi voir une machine à
calculer comme machin qui va analyser
une très longue suite de 0 et de 1 mais
surtout ses dents ça a été très longue
suite de 0 et durand qui est alors
encoder le programme est parfois le
programme ainsi exécuter va finir par
s'arrêter mais parfois le programme va
tourner en boucle jusqu'à l'infini et
bien la question que pose à cetin est la
suivante
imaginons un programme aléatoire c'est à
dire obtenu par un champion et qui tape
à chaque instant sur 0 ou sur un avec
probabilité 1/2 pour chaque option et ce
de manière indépendante de ses
précédentes frappent l'exécution de ce
programme terminera-t-elle ou plutôt
quelle est la probabilité que le
programme ainsi obtenu termine et bien
l'oméga de cetin est défini comme étant
la réponse à cette question
alors pour les matheux le nombre de
chats latine et plus souvent présenté
via la notion de code préfixe dont la
probabilité et un sur deux puissances
longueur du code
on peut vérifier qu'on observait ainsi
une loi de probabilité sur l'ensemble
des codes préfixe via notamment une
inégalité de kraft le méga de cetin est
la probabilité qu'un programme aléatoire
termine ok mais c'est quoi l'intérêt de
cette eau mega 7 aux médias contient-il
vraiment toutes les réponses de toutes
les mathématiques bien si le média de
channing contient bel et bien toutes ces
réponses et pour comprendre pourquoi il
est utile de comprendre le lien
fondamental entre la démonstration et le
calcul prenons le cas par exemple de la
conjecture de goldbach l'un des plus
près
thio problèmes encore ouvert des
mathématiques cette conjecture dit que
tout nombres entiers père supérieur à 4
et la somme de deux nombres premiers
par exemple si ce peut se décomposer en
3 + 3 ou 3 et bien un nombre premier de
même 8 est égal à 5 + 3 et 5 et 3 sont
tous les deux premiers ou encore 28 est
égal à 1 17 +11 ou 17 et 11 sont tous
deux premiers quasiment tous les
mathématiciens pense aujourd'hui que la
conjecture de code-barres est vrai mais
depuis deux cent soixante dix huit ans
personne n'a su le démontrer
et donc on n'est pas sûr que cette
conjecture soit vrai et bien ce que je
vais vous montrer c'est que pour
démontrer la conjecture de goldbach
il faut il suffit de comprendre un
programme en particulier
ce programme repose sur deux fonctions
la première détermine si un nombre paix
est premier la seconde c'est un nombre
paie peut-être écrit comme une somme de
deux nombres premiers
puis à chaque étape en commençant par n
égale 4 le programme va tester si n est
une somme de nombreux premiers si ce
n'est pas le cas alors on aura démontré
l'existence d'un nombre n qui contredit
la conjecture de goldbach
et si elle est bel et bien la somme de
deux nombres premiers
on passe aux nombreux experts suivants
en ajoutant deux à haisnes et on
recommence notre boucle
dès lors si ce programme s'arrête c'est
forcément parce que la conjecture de
goldbach est fausse al'inverse si le
programme tourner indéfiniment
c'est que pour tous nombreux n on aura
réussi à le décomposer en la somme de
deux nombres premiers
la conjecture de gaulle bar sera donc
vrai démontrer la conjecture de goldbach
est donc bel et bien un équivalent à
démontrer que notre programme ne termine
pas démontré si le programme termine ses
déterminer s'il existe une preuve de la
conjecture de goldbach
ok ça c'était pour la conjecture de
goldbach mais qu'en est t'il d'autres
théorème mathématique
peut-on vraiment démontré l'hypothèse de
riemann ou des théorèmes des
mathématiques non constructive
en étudiant si des programmes termine eh
bien je vais peut-être vous surprendre
mais c'est en fait pour répondre à cette
question précise que la science de
l'informatique a été inventée que ce
soit par alonso chuck ou par alan turing
tuerie niant en particulier voulait
réduire les mathématiques un problème de
terminaison d'algorithmes et des squats
il y est parvenu en 1936 tuerie a
démontré que les mathématiques n'était
rien d'autre qu'une branche de
l'algorithmique pour y arriver
turing à étudier
un programme très simple ce programme
prend en entrée une représentation
binaire d'un théorème à prouver ils
vérifient d'abord que le théorème et
syntaxiquement valide puis il va
parcourir l'ensemble de toutes les
preuves et testés pour chaque tentative
de preuves
si elle prouve vraiment le théorème en
question c'est une tentative de preuves
prouve le théorème alors le programme
s'arrête sinon il continué il s'agit
bien là d'un programme parfaitement
exécutable carré fonction syntaxe
éprouve ont été parfaitement spécifié
par des logiciens avant turing notamment
dans le cadre de la logique formelle
quant à l'ensemble proof des preuves
mathématiques il s'agit bien d'un
ensemble dénombrable qu'on peut
parcourir 100 ans a manqué un seul
en effet il suffit de commencer par
toutes les preuves d'une ligne puis
toutes les preuves de deux lignes puis
toutes celles de trois lignes et ainsi
de suite
la remarque crucial de turing c'est que
ce programme terminera si et seulement
si le théorème à une preuve
vous voyez pourquoi eh oui si le
théorème à une preuve
alors il viendra un moment où le
programme s'attaquera à cette preuve il
découvrira alors que cette preuve prouve
le théorème il s'arrêtera cependant si
le théorème n'a pas de preuve
le programme ne cessera jamais de
chercher cette preuve inexistante car
l'ensemble des tentatives de preuves est
infinie ainsi déterminer si ce programme
termine c'est déterminer l'existence
d'une démonstration du théorème t or
l'oméga de chat in encore en son sein la
terminaison de tous les algorithmes
en fait il suffit de connaître les
haines premiers beats de l'écriture en
base de l'oméga de cetin pour savoir si
les programmes de longueur elle termine
ou non donc en connaissant suffisamment
les beats de l'oméga cetin il est
possible de comprendre la terminaison de
programmes de faible longueur
or le programme vient de décrire est
particulièrement court du coup la vérité
de tout théorème mathématique peut être
déterminé à partir d'un nombre
relativement faible de beats de l'oméga
de cetin l'oméga contient bien tous les
mystères de toutes les mathématiques
alors bien sûr comme vous l'aurez deviné
il ya tout de même un hic dans cette
histoire
vous voyez lequel bien sûr le problème
c'est que l'oméga de cetin ne peut pas
être calculé
pire que ça il existe un énième but de
médias qui ne peut pas être calculé pour
une valeur malheureusement assez faible
de haine peut être disons n tour de sang
en fait même en admettant azf s'est on
ne connaît aujourd'hui que les 40
premiers beats de l'oméga à savoir
0,0001 0 et ainsi de suite pas dire tous
les chiffres que l'on connaît de las
vegas
comme pas mal ceci fait environ 0 0 6 2
7 5 4 1 de 0,9
il s'agit là à peu près de la
probabilité qu'un programme tirés au
hasard termine c'est déjà vraiment pas
mal comme approximations mais c'est en
fait insuffisant pour exploiter les
mystères de l'oméga pour résoudre des
mathématiques les secrets des
mathématiques sont enfuis un peu trop
profondément dans les décimales de
l'oméga
et malheureusement on sait que cela
restera à jamais le cas en effet grégory
cetin a démontré que peu importe les
mathématiques qu'on développe
pourvu que l'ensemble des actions soit
calculable nos mathématiques de pour mme
qu'égratigner la surface de l'oméga
l'oméga restera à jamais mystérieux et
ça c'est à la fois frustrant et
incroyablement fascinant
enfin à parler de l'existence du hasard
est ce que l'épistémologie quantitative
qui est l'informatique permet de dire à
ce sujet et geofroy fait remarquer que
les informaticiens met souvent en avant
une certaine mesure du degré de hasard
dans une information dans des données
qu'on appelle la complexité de
kolmogorov qui fait une fac a été
inventé d'abord parce limonov et avant
d'être inventée par kolmogorov et étant
moi même un énorme fan de soul rappelé à
la complexité de ce land of comme gore
découle aussi la caméra montée des
extrêmes des privés mais bon quand on a
sauvé neuf ce qui appartient à
solomonoff est donc cette complexité de
seulement 9 a décrit la compressibilité
d'un ensemble de données et
intuitivement si les données sont
extrêmement compressibles alors c'est
qu'ils contiennent de très très peu de
hasard inverse si elles sont très peu
compressibles c'est que finalement la
meilleure description des données et de
décrire les données elles mêmes et ça
c'est ce qu'on aurait si les données
étaient purement aléatoire pour en
savoir plus je vous renvoie notamment
vers la vidéo que j'ai fait sur la
profondeur logique de bennett qui est
également à payer toutes ces histoires à
6,2 des dragons suggère que peut-être
que le hasard serait la différence entre
deux univers s'il était redouté
sauf que bien sûr ça pose la question
des compétitions initial notamment de
l'univers et alors il serait tentant de
dire que si l'univers contient un hasard
fondamental alors même avec les mêmes
conditions initiales l'univers aurait
plusieurs futurs possibles mais il
faudra faire un petit peu gaffe quand on
dit ça parce que en fait le hasard d'un
mental ici pourrait en fait être
encodées dans des beats secret donc
typiquement quand on imagine une machine
de turing capable de tirer du hasard une
façon de faire c'est de considérer que
la machine de turing disposeront de ces
données de base mais elle a accès à côté
de ça à un autre au ruban qui contient
un ensemble de beats qui ont été pré
tiré de façon aléatoire ou qui suivent
des lois du hasard
et du coup à chaque instant cette
machine de turing pourrait tirer au
hasard des données de la 7e rue ben
contenant l'aléatoire et si on considère
que sept autres rubans aléatoire
finalement en tout cas les parties
utilisées de ce sept autres rubans font
partie de l'univers
et j'ai envie de dire pourquoi pas alors
le comportement de l'univers avec son
ruban en puces seraient concrètement
déterministe et serait indiscernable
d'un univers qui serait vraiment
fondamentalement aléatoire du coup la
question de son reboot et l'univers est
ce qu on obtiendra des univers
différents reviendrait à la question de
s que les bits tiré de façon aléatoire
pour booster cet univers seront les
mêmes dans les deux univers et
finalement si ses beats juste prix
existent et sont ajoutés à la bande
originale de la machine de turing
universel et bien il serait beaucoup
plus naturelle de dire qu'en fait ces
beats supposément aléatoire fait font
partie de l'état initial de l'univers je
sais pas si c'était ultra clair ce que
je viens de raconter mais en gros l'idée
fondamentale celle que le hasard peut
être décrite comme faisant partie de
notre univers auquel cas il n'y a plus
de hasard fondamentale et comme les deux
modèles sont complètement isolés horde
en tout cas d'un point de vue
observationnelles il n'y a absolument
aucune façon de faire différence entre
un duvet rhin fondamentalement aléatoire
créé un univers purement déterministe
affaire terry âgées l'est avec les
vidéos la prochaine fois on va continuer
un peu dans le monde
les mariés de l'informatique et au riz
avec un autre paradoxe que je vais
appeler le paradoxe de chico del du nom
du mathématicien qui me l'a présenté et
c'est un paradoxe qui vous verrez est à
la fois très sains jeunes et également
assez facile qui va nous amener petit
appétit à parler de solomonoff vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez à vérifier pour
s'abonner pour ces épisodes version du
cordon et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois et est en baisse à terre
oui 12 following les fluos l'imaginaire
expérimente oui collecte aux to other
101,6 about that they did sauf au point
oméga right from any other in fine est
éliminé au ministère mais nos fringues
quelqu'un pour un être humain
the most powerful système par
mathématiques 6 notables pour les villes
mot enfin entre les manies bit of this
love